here in this video we are going to
showcase the list of the top 10 most
powerful symbiotes you know this
symbiotic alien species that venom and
riot belongs to they are also known as
the klintar they are amorphous symbiotic
extraterrestrials created from the
living abyss at the beginning of the
universe by the primordial deity null
who manifested a sword of living
darkness called the all black from his
shadow to slaughter the celestials as
you can see they are quite up there in
power and one thing that is important is
that symbiotes offspring is always
another magnitude more powerful than its
parents and since venom and riot are
first generation they don't even feature
on the list the ones that do are
insanely strong so let's dive into this
madness
number 10 scream scream was the only one
of the five
live foundation symbiotes who was not
assimilated to the composite creature
called the hybrid instead it and the
host donna diego went their separate
ways donna's mine alongside with the
symbiotes inexperienced and immaturity
gradually turn scream into an
unpredictable and volatile entity with a
few insignificant exceptions such as her
ability to lengthen her hair into
tendrils for attack purposes her
abilities were comparable to those of
venom symbiotes scream was very powerful
but it was killed by eddie brock when he
incapacitated it with sonic feedback and
stabbing her to death with a hot knife
number nine anti-venom when eddie
brock's body became infected with cancer
he acquired a completely new species of
symbiote by chance during brock's cancer
treatment a series of circumstances
unexpectedly led fragments of the venom
symbiote to merge with his white blood
cells the outcome was a symbiote with no
self-awareness basically turning it into
a benign biological costume over which
eddie brock had full and complete
control
it had the same abilities as venom but
with additional improvements including
immunity to sonic and fire assaults
number 8 mania technically not a
symbiote entity unto itself mania
originated as a piece of the venom
symbiote severed in battle which
displayed far more bloodlust and wrath
than its parent that's partly because of
its wearer andy benton who was also
cursed with the hellmark a supernatural
brand the mania symbiote has been
transmitted into a criminal name lee
price and lee has demonstrated a
capacity to enslave others by infecting
them with bits of the symbiote making
him far more powerful than venom and
spiderman combined
number 7 sleeper in comparison to others
that came from venom the sleeper
symbiote was quite unique this symbiote
had very different appearance from the
venom symbiote and lacked some of the
symbiote straits such as the iconic
ornamented white eyes it was also
haughty yet fateful a symbiote that
defended its host despite its occasional
violence sleeper is venom's seventh
offspring and shares many of his
progenitor's talents such as webbing
creation and camouflage sleeper became
an anti-hero just like venom later on
number six hybrid when the doomsday
obsessed live foundation kidnapped eddie
brock and separated him from his
symbiote the organization forcibly
plucked five gestating offsprings from
the alien organism that is riot phage
lasher agony and scream which would then
become the symbiotes that would form
hybrid despite the fact that scream and
its host donna diego escaped the
remaining four were eventually combined
into the justile entity hybrid when it
linked with a jail guard called scott
washington whose own individuality
wrestle for dominance amongst the others
in a mixture it became a chaotic mix
being a combo of four other symbiotes
hybrid was very powerful
number five carnage in any symbiote list
carnage is essentially one of the top
dogs always carnage outperforms venom in
terms of power and destructive potential
as much as venom outperforms spider-man
in terms of strength the symbiote
organism was the offspring of venom who
teamed up with serial killer called
cletus quesadilly to become one of
marvel's most heinous super villains
with significantly greater strength and
abilities than venom this new symbiote
was even more powerful and dangerous and
bloodthirsty even though venom would
defeat his skit several times he was
essentially outmatched the entire time
relying on luck and width to win
number 4 toxin what threat may compel
venom and carnage to put their
differences aside and work together
well that would be toxin
carnage first symbiote offspring and as
we said before the offspring is always
more powerful than the parent toxin was
immediately identified by carnage as a
major threat as it essentially combines
the strength and mind of venom and
carnage in one despite the anti-hero i
mean venoms hatred for carnage it opted
to train the toxin symbiote to be a
force for good it eventually formed a
friendship with patrick mulligan a new
york city cop who went to become a
superhero his abilities were comparable
to dose of carnage and venom but on a
different level of power
number three is gone when carnage was
isolated from its long-term hosts serial
killer cletus cassidy it was chemically
lobotomized and collected in the hopes
of developing a new line of prosthetics
the result was scorned being a symbiote
developed from an experimental merger of
extraterrestrial biology and earth
technology and it can connect with
computer systems and absorb and adapt
all types of cybernetic modifications
and weaponry it can burn and interface
with numerous machines which means that
she not only has the strength to equal
carnage and even beat him
she can also use sonic and thermal
weapons against other klyntars at will
number 2 grendel this unique symbiote
was created by nile the clinton god it
is significantly more powerful than any
typical symbiote like venom carnage or
right and was capable of destroying
deity-like entities like celestials well
as a symbiote dragon
the usual symbiote weaknesses to fire
and sonic weaponry aren't as dangerous
and it can actually breathe fire and
release energy blasts
it had the speed of the silver surfer
and was super durable grendel like many
other symbiote dragons could combine
with others to form a super large
monster in many configurations such as
the chihu which is also one of marvel's
most powerful monsters
and number 1
null for years the extraterrestrial
samirds were thought to be a bestial
race with primordial roots
it was null who was shown that he was
the one who created them he was a being
with enormous god-like abilities who
lived through the period of oblivion
well some say before the creation of the
universe null carries a sword rather
from a celestial's undead corpse and his
strength is unrivalled he created the
symbiotes by accident and discovered
that he could utilize them as an army he
has dominion over symbiotes and those
born from their biology because he
created them any character who can
slaughter celestials is without a doubt
one of the most powerful beings in the
marvel universe
and so with that we come to the end of
the video on the top 10 most powerful
klintar symbiotes you know the venom
symbiotes
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to be a part of our mind cue
family and we can't hardly wait for
venom let there be carnage
oh
monsters right so anyway click that
thumbs up button for support
and also smash that bell button for
regular updates on new monster videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam
you